anti-vaccine truckers are now blocking
three border crossings between the u.s
and canada now the biden administration
is putting new pressure on canada to end
the protest chris van cleave is in
detroit near the blocked ambassador
bridge which carries about 25 percent of
all trade
between the u.s and canada chris good
morning
well good morning that works out to
around 390 million dollars in goods a
day most of that moved by big rigs now
the economic fallout has hit at least
five of the world's biggest auto makers
with production disruptions and one
estimate put lost wages just for
michigan residents just this week at
more than 51 million dollars
this morning marks the fifth day of the
nation's most lucrative trade route
remaining closed as canadian protesters
blockade the ambassador bridge it's
forcing truckers to drive to a different
smaller border crossing about two hours
outside of detroit it doesn't take a lot
to shut the bridge down bruce heyman is
the former u.s ambassador to canada this
moves from a legitimate i think protest
over a vaccine mandate to now putting
the economy and lives at risk that's a
very impactful thing i hope that we
resolve quickly brian hitchcock owns a
trucking company outside lansing he's
parked trailers that would normally make
daily runs between detroit and canada
it's 40 percent of his business which he
says was already struggling in part due
to vaccine mandates what does that mean
for your bottom line the mandate was
affecting it anyways because we were
having a shortage of drivers that were
vaccinated so we were falling behind
every week so this just magnified it as
the economic fallout grows pressure is
mounting on canadian leaders i have been
on the horn with our canadian ambassador
with the white house i mean i am
imploring them to get this resolved the
so-called freedom convoy also continues
to clog the streets of canada's capital
ottawa
and the protests have now spread
globally from a blockade outside the new
zealand parliament to a trucker convoy
making its way across france
in the u.s the department of homeland
security is now surging staff to their
incident command post in los angeles
following a warning about a possible
trucker protest during super bowl sunday
now canadian leaders from justin trudeau
the prime minister down have started to
call these blockades illegal actions the
community of windsor just across the
river here they're seeking an injunction
to force the blockade protesters to move
and clear the bridge we also know that
canadian police the royal canadian
mounted police and provincial police are
massing reinforcements if they're needed
vlad
all right chris van cleeve thank you
very much